okay so here's the thing i'm thinking
that i should probably put the helmet on
now
i am about to unbox segway shoes
now that's not actually what they're
called they're called the segway drift
w1 and
you guys remember the hoverboards well
this is basically like a tiny hoverboard
on each one of your feet we've got one
here it looks like a mystery box
but i assure you this mystery is going
to be solved very soon i guess i can
take the helmet off that's a little
excessive
so i didn't cut the tape i was trying to
peek in here because i wanted to do a
pre-unboxing
the problem was it was boxed very nicely
so i wasn't able to instructions these
are going to be extremely important
segway drift w1 user manual is that
going to be me
later do not traverse
bumps or uneven terrain do not ride on
public roads motorways highways or
streets
avoid slopes steeper than 10 degrees
do not ride through puddles oh there's
something else this looks important as
well
this is one of those things where i do
not throw the instructions away
one wheel a knee pad it does look like a
knee pad i've also brought knee pads and
a lot of stuff pulled up to the seam
with masculinism
i've used segway products in the past
this is kind of crazy when i went to
college i was actually
a i don't even know how to explain it i
gave tours of my college
and we were one of the first colleges to
ever have a segway so we had one and i
would ride the segway and i'd wear a
helmet since this was so early a lot of
people didn't even know what the segway
was
it was kind of cool to be able to see
how far they've come
i also had one of the segway nine bots
which was sort of
the actual hoverboards and using segway
technology was something that is so much
more trusting than some of those
hoverboards because
the people that were making those there
were some really crabby hoverboards and
catching on fire they weren't catching
on fire
and when i saw that segway was doing one
i knew that this was a brand that can be
trusted
see how this charges so here's our
charging cable i'm glad i brought my
skateboarding helmet
so that i would be ready i also brought
my skateboarding knee pads and
elbow pads one cable so this is this
plugs into here and then this plugs into
the wall and it looks like there's two
separate little charging cables to
charge each one of these
shoes segue shoes another thing
you guys can't tell these are really
heavy like this is it's not like these
are light
maybe like seven pounds each
what do you think do you wanna have an
eight pound weight should we you wanna
yeah get the weight i'm pretty sure
this is actually a really good weight
because this will help you with your
grip strength as well
god i'm feeling so shredded right now i
think it's about seven and a half pounds
3.5 kilograms times two
3.5 kilograms is how many pounds that
would be 7.72 pounds
yeah i said seven and a half so that's
pretty accurate now that i know that i'm
a genius
at everything it sets the girl with the
helmet on
gosh i'm gonna make so many friends
today yeah so there's the charging port
okay we'll charge this up okay we can
stop filming now okay
cool we're gonna let this charge and
we're gonna go outside guys
looks like they're charged the first
thing it told us to do
in the directions that i read were put
them
down like this to get them calibrated so
this puts it into like calibration mode
[Music]
they're calibrating right now look how
pretty
one thing it did say is not to touch the
wheel only thing i want to do is touch
it but look at me i'm not i'm being safe
[Music]
come on it is powered on and parked on
the ground
[Music]
standby mode and then it goes into
balance mode
when you slightly tip it so let's see
and put this on because
yeah no pets
oh i'm doing it i'm doing it
oh my goodness when they s
okay so i'm a little
unsteady because your legs
it's weird it's weird how do i even
explain oh god there's a carpet over
here
my legs are doing something it's like my
legs are not communicating with
not only my brain but with each other
i'm not sure how to explain it because
basically
you just move your feet and like it goes
that way and the thing is i've used the
segway 9 blocks before i've used the
hoverboards before
the one thing i never really tried
although i did give it a shot was the
rocket shoes
those were incredibly dangerous because
they went so fast whereas this is
different because you're not actually
strapped into it
your feet are free they're free your
feet are free
i'm gonna need to clear out all the
furniture in my house now i don't know
if i'm
street ready i should probably just do a
hallway first well my legs are spreading
apart i do not want that to happen
like that's the thing is when these kind
of get like this like you got to really
use some muscles to sort of like
force your legs back together i'm all
geared up if you're wondering why these
may look a little bit tight it's because
they're children's
safety first the handle is actually
quite handy
all right let's go how's my posture
it sounds like i'm on a spaceship i'm
not ready for full speed yet
like what if one leg decides to do
something else
i think this is as fast as i can go
i don't think he's home
oh my god
i have been ringing your doorbell for
like 15 minutes
what are those so far so good but i came
to visit you i was like i don't know
what matt's doing
hello hello nice jersey shirt that's
nice
can i try uh the fact that you have
elbow knee pads and a helmet though oh
this is for my skateboard days
camo as well seems like a very distinct
thing to do oh yes okay so now they're
balanced you basically just
you just hop on what are my legs doing
okay so we found that now we're gonna go
find ed and we're gonna cruise around in
the parking garage and i'm gonna get
some really cool slow-mo shots
to make it look like i'm really cool
hello
yeah go to the parking garage uh what
floor
i don't know so right now i'm practicing
i'm feeling pretty good
feeling pretty good about it
have you seen anything cooler than this
what do you think ed what do you think
of these do you think is cool
i think it's kind of neat just the other
day i was like listening to old music
and i was like man i remember roller
skating
like in elementary school and how cool
that was and it might not be cool again
and then
now it is look at this stuff isn't it
neat
wouldn't you think my segway
collection's complete
we made it outside let's ride around and
get it get what i don't know
does that mean something bad see my legs
sometimes do this so you gotta like
really get them back together
this is handling this sidewalk
incredible
[Music]
so they turn off after a minute if no
one's on them which is probably a really
good thing because it'll save your
battery they do work
independent of each other so they're not
actually both connected so this was the
one that i had on my left foot before
and now it's on the right so it doesn't
really matter there's no left or right
these are it
these are the segway drift w1
they should have been called segway
shoes because that's way cooler
but if you do want to change the name
don't forget you heard it here first
thank you guys so much for watching this
video i had so much fun trying these out
and the surprising thing is they do
look really dangerous but so far they
were so much easier to ride than i
thought when i watched the demo video
so if you guys want to check these out
i'll put a link in the description and
i'm having so much fun trying them
yo what's up you like my shoes they're
segway shoes
baby what that's exactly what matt said
really yes he goes what but he was being
entirely serious like what are those
what are those you're not going over any
crazy bumps or any elevations it says
you're not supposed to go
up like 10 degrees pretty steep it's
like maybe more than a parking garage
show me come here here i am the ground
okay cool we're gonna get run over i am
gonna get run over all right guys we'll
see you later thanks for watching don't
forget to subscribe be sure to hit the
bell
so that you'll be notified when i post
new videos i hate that i have to say
that it's so so
icky sing it icky yeah sing it makes it
cool kiki
do you love me or you ride in on your
[Music]
segway
you